hey guys welcome back to the waterlab
podcast i'm james marshall and this
episode is brought to you by the wallet
coffee yes the freshly roasted coffee
bean made here ryden nelson at pomeroy's
is one of the greatest coffee beans you
will ever try so if you are keen to give
it a go head over to waterlab.com click
the coffee link at the top and you'll be
good to go also if you're keen to wrap
some lad merch now is a great time as a
hundred percent of the profits will be
going to the great cause gumboot friday
so if you are keen to become a lad and
rip some lad kit head over to
waterloo.com and it's easy as from there
anyway i have a great guest here all
ready to go so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lad rydo team another episode in another
lad and before all the tasman marco led
shoot off to their various super rugby
teams i thought i'd better get on as
many as i can over the next few weeks
and today's guest he is a champion lad
who is in my opinion one of the most
underrated players in the country who
has had a really unique journey to date
in and out of the game which i'm really
looking forward to hearing all about he
is the great man himself willie harville
welcome mate cheers jimmy mark good to
be here mate great to have you in this
studio i know you're a big listener of
the podcast so it's great to have you on
yeah big listener i've had a few what's
your favorite one probably your
brother's is it yeah he's up there um
corny's was pretty average
is pretty good
and
also like hunty's one as well oh yeah
all the tassy lads big fan anyway mate
big news for you last week yeah it was
pretty unexpected to be honest yeah i
haven't really played much tassie season
this year but
i think my agent sort of put it out
there
at the start of the year when
they sort of got their whole minor
pacific thing going on and
he sort of handed my name to aaron major
and then
so it was like about
about three weeks into the season so
then we had that covered break
and then
they wanted to fill my um preseason
games so that canterbury and 20s one
then
they like what they've seen out of that
canterbury one
i was playing 10 then yeah and then i
just hope i could get a bit of game time
with tazzy so then
got a few game time and then yeah a
little eventuated from there then agent
sorted out a contract and then there was
it got a call from
aaron major it was probably about three
weeks ago yeah just had a good old yarn
to him he's a good lad too yeah first
time he was talking to him so
yeah and then yeah that's about it how
good sam they signed you as a 10 or 15
because i know you've been 10 majority
of your career today but this year
managed to find yourself at 15 for most
of it yeah um i prefer to be at 10 yeah
but
the conversation on the phone with um as
it was get out there and then you do
your job
if that's 10 or 15 then you just nail it
the best of your abilities so
if that's 15 then i'm happy to learn
that i'm still learning they're still
pretty fresh there so
but hopefully you get to learn off the
likes of um lily whanau and stuff like
that
the moana so that should give me a bit
of game understanding at 15 all that
sort of stuff but i do prefer 10. true
yeah so he's there and lincoln
is there so it looks pretty good as well
yeah he's been he's had a good year but
um obviously there's a good opportunity
for you to get some taste at the next
level so you must be pretty excited
about that yeah i'm pretty pumped though
probably one of the dream games would be
coming against my brother yeah probably
get a better needle out there
all those backyard days
if i get one back on them
who used to win the backyard games i'd
come off second best most of the times
to be honest yeah had the size of me and
the age so how many years older is he
it's about almost four years oh four
years i had a decent age gap i was
probably i'd probably be running around
there at five and he'd be nine yeah
sometimes i'll get dragged out and i
didn't even want to play but yeah i've
come and cried a few times but
mum didn't really
she said you wanted to go out there so
that's got left behind in the dark so
i've got a funny story about it he's
like last try wins because that's that
was pretty much the rule back then yeah
couldn't go inside so someone scored
pretty much until i scored
and then
i was running down the side i went to
dive and he's freaking pushed me and
i've wrapped my ribs around this tree
and i've gone on the side crying and
then yeah that was it
[Laughter]
let's put you in pretty good stead going
forward because you for your size mate
you are one of the toughest players
pound for pound going around yeah
i sort of got used to it when i was
younger just were out in the backyard
pretty much every day when we could and
even in the rain and everything and
when i started playing rugby first i was
i was actually free
so i was just i was actually down there
watching my brother play rugby and um
one of the
uh my mum was friends with one of the
people from the under fives yeah the
manager and they asked if i wanted to
just run on and have a game yeah but it
was touch at that time i didn't know and
then i had this baggy ass top throw it
down to my knees
and then
i've tried to tackle the referee i just
i used to tackle
i hadn't done anything else with my
brother i just tackle and then yeah
that's how it all eventuated
i've probably played from when i was
like three i played two years upper
grade or until i got to high school
pretty much yeah i caught up in age wow
that's awesome so what else do you know
about moana pacifica like we're about to
train and uh where do you have to live
and all that stuff uh
it's at mount smart oh is that so the
warriors facility because i'm pretty
sure they're still in aussie yeah so
we're looking for a house do you know
any of the other guys who are going to
be up there
uh just tazzy boys yeah at the moment
probably look to get get to know a few
of the lads a bit more when you get out
there so it'll be awesome
yeah i was hoping to get a place with
jim the brass oh yeah yeah but we'll see
what happens there
i've got to get on to it
they'll have you bulking in no time yeah
that man's a beast
and how do you reckon moana's going to
go like pretty happy with the squad
they've formed
yeah so far looks like a pretty good
squad there's actually a bit of
experience in there as well
with a mix of young talent as well so
yeah i reckon we'll
we'll give it a good crack we just get
got to find that chemistry i guess that
cohesion and get a get a good culture on
there and it should be good
and we spoke a little bit about your um
time at tasmania this season playing at
fullback have you found the whole year
as a whole for you um yeah i've really
enjoyed today it's it's good being back
in the environment
all the guys are bloody good lads and i
haven't been in any other environment
but yeah i probably rate it up there's
one of the best in new zealand for
provincial everyone's just so welcoming
and everyone gets along and it's coaches
as well and i
go up to them they're approachable and
it's easy to talk to them
and do you think your time at 15's
helped your game as a 10 going forward
um yeah probably a just
with the scanning and stuff you probably
see a bit more up 15 so then you're
seeing different pitches out there and
when you come in you sort of know what
you're looking for when you're looking
out wide and stuff like that so probably
just the scanning aspect of it and
probably the ears on thing
the demandiness so if when you're at 10
and you
they're demanding it then you know you
know it's on so yeah you're going to
have a massive year for moana can't wait
pre-season that'll be a grind first
everyone
oh it's true yeah you didn't do a
pre-season before no i've never done a
super free season so it'll be pretty
good
good to have a bloody good blowout
you're going to come back massive i hope
so so what wait are you because you're
yeah you do play at a pretty light
weight don't you yeah um i'm 83 kilos
yeah so
well not the first time i played for
tassie i was only 78. were yeah
but i was still a spring chicken and how
old were you
i just turned 20. yeah so i was at the
squad when i was 19. so yeah a couple
couple years out of school and then yeah
mate guru i know we've already talked to
your brother about a little bit of your
upbringing but pretty keen to hear your
side of
the story so you obviously grew up in
mott yeah with your brother and your dad
who's a rugby legend around nelson as
well so what else what else have you got
to tell us about your upbringing
yeah i was born in mott
morocco so
i'm the i'm the true mott legion
davey was born in nelson oh was he
osborne
yeah
so
growing up in my all my life yeah um i
went to primary school in town called
parking school bloody good school
good for primary school love playing
rugby at lunch here yeah
and then after that went to
my high for two years
and um really enjoyed my rugby there too
um
warmer mates there still mates of them
to this day good lads as well
and then after that decided to go to
nelson college
i was a border at foul house so yeah
what was the reason behind the move uh
yeah a little bit rugby my brother went
there and said enjoyed the experience i
was actually going to get seen in year
nine oh yeah and then mum said nah we'll
just leave you here for a couple more
years yeah
and then yeah so pretty much my brother
said it was pretty cool experience in
the boarding life stuff so yeah i'll
give it a crack and then
and also the rag ba um
bit more of a challenge i guess
playing outside of the just the region
like not just first in the same people
every week and week out so
probably just the challenge of it did
you get a scholarship to go there uh
just like a half scholarship
but yeah it was all good because you
were a bit of a gun at a young age too
weren't you coming through the ranks
yeah i wouldn't say a gun i was just
just a normal boy
just enjoying it with my mates back at
my high but yeah lifelong friends and at
the first 15 my first memory of you was
coming to watch you play i think it was
wellington college in a quad final up
there and mate you were at 10 and you
were like i reckon you would have been
under 50 kgs back then but matt you were
into it you were chopping everyone
jacklin you got so many turnovers you
were just you're just an animal out
there so talk to me a little bit about
your um first 15 days
yeah so i made the team in year 11 well
originally because
went over at the end of year 10 because
they had like a
sort of like a first 15 training day
yeah
so i went over there did all that stuff
but
sort of come up to me after the um after
the training they said oh
yeah good to get to know you and stuff
like that and
you're coming to school next year but
there's probably um no year 11's we're
going to be looking at all right and so
i was like oh that's sweet as i wasn't
too pleased about that i'll just play
seconds or something like that
and then
so
i ended up not going to any of the like
first 15 camps or anything because oh
well they told me i'm not going to make
it so i'll just stay around and do
seconds and stuff like that and i ended
up i ended up playing for um nelson aids
with my brother the club team yeah
so i was about 15 and then
he just rang me up because i don't think
a
school season had started yeah so he
just rang my ass if i wanted to go oh
yeah jump on the bench sure and then got
on for about 20 minutes let me take
conversion got a conversion and then
following week played again sat on the
bench
so did you ever play with your old man
at um now sorry football club yeah i did
get a couple games yeah what was that
like playing with your man and your
brother whole family out there yeah it's
pretty cool a
bit weird yeah
dad's always giving away penalty
no he gotta try actually dave set him up
where were you playing
i was on the wing oh yeah i just get
checked on the way yeah yeah
i don't know as long as i'm on the park
yeah yeah i actually played a bees game
with my dad as well for nelson anything
hey i got a i got a 90 meter intercept
but he was offside
called back
started spraying him
oh that's classic
and so what was your pathway from school
because you didn't make new zealand
schools or anything like that did you
say your pathway was a little bit more
no just um
through the crusaders academy yeah than
that for three years it was just
straight out of school they sort of had
a like a pre-academy yeah when we're at
school so there's a few of us going
there
like six in the morning the gym session
and come back
make the boarding house and do all that
stuff so they're grind day they're
really growing that sort of set us up a
little bit
and then went into that after school
three years in there that's pretty good
three years
a bit tough at times though like
balancing
all my work stuff and stuff because
i'm not discrediting it but there's
people just studying and stuff like that
yeah and then there was a few of us that
were um tradies and doing
doing all that so we're just out on the
tools all day yeah probably get up at
about 5 30
roll onto the gym at six and
do the gym session
finish all that then
head over to work do that and then
sometimes come back after trainings and
you'd have like skills and all that sort
of stuff so it's a pretty big day to
massive hey so were you doing that
straight from school you got you started
your building then yeah i started
pretty much because i didn't come back
for term four yeah so i
didn't really have many exams to be
honest
you were straight there for rugby i
wasn't really a freak in the class to be
honest not the smartest one in the past
um so i left after term three pretty
much
and then yes started my building
apprenticeship
and then
yeah the academy started up in like
november i'm pretty sure yeah for a
couple couple months and you know it's
christmas so yeah well you're thinking
rugby as a pathway you'd obviously seen
your brother sort of go through it
before you so was that sort of your
inspiration to
try and follow that rugby pathway as
well
yeah it
probably would have been to be honest
and
i've seen him playing tasman a few times
i've watched all his games yeah and how
he came up
he's pretty much didn't really make all
the the team and stuff like that so
and then yeah but it was probably a big
driving factor yeah and being in tasman
as well
be awesome to get play with them as well
so
it was that and then yeah that was
pretty much the driving factor yeah and
how did you find the building you
mentioned the long days but did you did
you enjoy the building yeah the building
was the building was fun when you got a
good crew it's all good yeah that's
pretty easy when you've got a deck of
performances
my formulas are good they're all good
yeah sometimes get a bit hard in the
summertime um because you'll just be on
the tools of the day sometimes you just
have the shedders jobs like
digging pile holes for a dick and it's
just so solid yeah and then you come in
and go to do weights and all that sort
of stuff and you sort of you've already
already burnt out because you're in the
sun and it's about 25 degrees and you've
been in the sun for night now yeah
you're going to come in and jim
found that quite hard but just push
through it yeah did you find it hard to
keep your weight on doing those big
shifts in the sun like you're talking
about yeah yeah i did because i've got a
pretty fast metabolism too yeah so i
could imagine i pretty much eat anything
and it goes off me yeah yeah that was
pretty hard
like because you only get like 10
o'clock smoko and that's only like 15
minutes yeah you get a half an hour
lunch
and sometimes you wouldn't even have a
last smoker because you just
the boss just wants you to work yeah or
you can just charge it on to the end of
the day yeah finish area yeah and then
do all that so sometimes i'll probably
get breakfast my smoker then lunch sure
and then i'll shoot off to the gym so i
got i don't really have much time
afterwards yeah straight to the gym
yeah so mate now it's probably
one of the best meal prep
and so
how did you make your tasman debut so a
couple years later so yeah um
2017 club season was pretty good enjoyed
all that that was good i was in all the
water training stuff
yeah all that stuff and they said yeah
just keep doing what you're doing for
next year and then
2018 i had a pretty good season uh
probably my best season to be honest
yeah i was enjoying it and stuff like
that
it was almost top tri scorer top point
scorer
and then after that season rangi sort of
got me and it was sort of just a
like a training one leon mcdonald yeah
yeah it was a weekly training one and
then
it was just like a just a learning
experience getting there learning off
everyone and all that and then
i think it was a game against
it was probably seeking food the last
round
so that came aboard they told me on
sunday so they paid me for
to be honest i probably was
nervous as hell yeah yeah i was probably
i was actually anxious oh yeah yeah it's
like butterflies
pretty normal yeah i think a bit better
now though way better now yeah and then
yeah come on
first ever provincial touch kick the
ball out on the fault
was davey play yeah all i landed on the
line
and he just spayed me
[ __ ]
then yeah but that was that was a little
blur went pretty fast for me to be
honest yeah
probably i wouldn't say i wasn't ready
but it was probably a bit underprepared
yeah to be honest did you feel like
mistakes like that really hammered you
like did you really get affected by an
early mistake or something like that
yeah probably like that when it's in
your first touch from your debut game
yeah i was like
[ __ ]
that's me i'm done
i'll never get in the game
that's what i thought yeah
sort of hammered in my head that yeah
now i'm
just next job focus but back then
probably yeah
so you obviously did enough to get
eventually get called up to the blues
didn't you so how did that all come
about yeah i got caught up to the blues
um i think they had a few injuries at 10
yeah so peripheral was
pretty much out for the season i think
he'd done his pick and then
they just had plums and oats so
rangy gave me a call and asked me to go
up go up there so i was up there for
three months and then yeah
sort of i found it quite hard up there
to be honest yeah talk to me about this
because i do know i have spoken to you a
few times over a few brews about it and
it's always been an interesting yarn for
me so talk to me about like the whole
experience going up there to the blues
because i know it was tough yeah um
the play all the players are great real
good bunch of leads and stuff like that
i think it's just that as a replacement
player
like
you're joining them in season eight yeah
everyone's already connected
sort of probably didn't put myself out
there a bit more as i want to yeah stuff
like that but
got there sort of bounced around a bit i
was an airbnb for like four weeks yeah
by yourself yeah by myself just in the
middle of town sure didn't have a car or
anything how did you get around i
actually got a ride from jed brown oh
yeah yeah so he was living close by but
i was uber into trading for the first
few times yeah
and then
after that got put in the heritage hotel
that was a pretty good hotel
i was up there for two weeks
and then after that they said oh you
just and i didn't really say you're in
for the seasons like week by week yeah
because they didn't know where stevie
was going to come back yeah
i was just sort of unknown i couldn't
and i didn't have a car or anything so
like i found it quite hard just to get
around like that how do i have to ask
people to get around and be like oh can
i get a ride that sort of stuff yeah
sort of just felt like a
bit rubbed yourself yeah me right here
yes and that
so then
yeah they can put with blake gibson yeah
so
probably yeah i was probably a ship
flatmate to be honest
um i just skipped to myself probably
just stayed in my room just kept to
myself
yeah that's pretty much what i did and
what was it like like in the training
environment did you feel comfortable
training with the boys you hadn't played
a huge amount at npc level but did you
feel comfortable to be in that
environment yeah the training
environment was good i enjoyed it i sort
of knew a few boys out there from tassie
as well so
that was good the training environment
was good i enjoyed all that
that was good it's probably just the the
outside of the stuff of it yeah i've
enjoyed all the training but then just
after training i was
uh [ __ ] what do i do now yeah your
changing room was yeah it's kind of
weird it's like separate yeah so they
got the main chain new room and then
there's a separate one we're just the
replacement players and then the coaches
are there sure oh yeah you're the
coaches in the replacement place yeah
how many replacement players are there
uh sometimes you'd be like six of us in
there yeah but most of the time would
just be me and i'd just be i'll just be
yawning to um
me and tana and me
and all the teams next door yeah sure
that's quite weird
from the ending yeah but some days was
good because then they had about 10
replacement players and when we had sort
of our like gst high yeah yeah
did you feel excluded from the team or
did you feel a part of it um
probably a little bit excluded because
of the the
arrangements you're sitting in yeah
when you're getting changed and stuff
because i know the crusaders they have
all the injury guys
sitting in the middle of the yeah thing
i don't know what it's like other places
yeah but no i felt included in the in
the team stuff yeah that sort of stuff i
sort of got to know a few of the boys
quite quite good
um tj farney is real good he's a good
lad
um i sort of just hang out with like
levi and stuff like that yeah because
just because i knew them yeah yeah and
who he hung out with
yeah probably could have put myself out
there a bit more
yeah well you got another opportunity
yeah a few few months say going up to
moana it's going to be a pretty similar
experience i'd imagine yeah it'll be
good i'll probably put myself out there
a bit more get to know the lads and then
because i'm probably into a bit of stuff
now
i didn't play golf or anything back then
yes i was sort of just playing my
playstation and just like talking to my
mates back home because that's how i
just connect with them yeah and then
yeah now i've got got some hobbies
played golf pretty
not not the best golfer
but yeah
golfing pokies pokey's now
but that's leeway
blame him
he got you addicted not addicted
[Laughter]
and then so following that your time up
there what was the next steps because
you sort of
took a step away from rugby for a while
so what was that and yeah
i was sort of when i was in auckland i
wasn't playing club baby out there so i
was just flying back down and playing
for nelson
and all that sort of stuff so i probably
played
three or four games for nelson yeah when
i was still with the club and
i don't know some days i just i'd go
come back
and then like when i was
getting on the field
i didn't even want to play yeah sort of
mentally i said oh
so i wasn't enjoying it yeah was that
from the blues or was that just in
general you think just had enough uh
but maybe a little bit from the blues
and sort of just sort of had enough like
yeah i sort of lost the enjoyment yeah
playing i was just playing because i had
to now yeah so that sort of stuff and
yeah
so i
did that
and then i was like oh
no i need to take a break like
i probably put too much pressure on
myself to be honest
that was probably a big one like
pressure just because my brother's done
all that all that sort of stuff i
thought oh i've got to get there this
fast that fast you know so oh
no i just want to
take some time away and finish off my
building apprenticeship so
one of my good mates by my best mate um
got my job with him started my building
apprenticeship back up i was already
about two and a half years for it
started back up in 2019 and then
finished off my apprenticeship
at
the start of this year
and then thought i'd just
give rugby a crack again just enjoy it
so
i gotta change the scenery come back
home play for the local club here which
is really real good because all my mates
from school played for them
and then yeah that was i enjoyed that a
lot because i was actually
in 2020 i played a couple bees games
yeah just to play with my good mates
that they sort of don't really play
competitive rugby they just play b's
yeah enjoy i had a couple games for that
and that was pretty fun and i enjoyed it
but then i said ah
kind of a bit of a challenge
so then i um because i was working in
blenheim at the time last year yeah for
a bit
so i was like oh
i rang their kyrie coach oh brendan
asked me if i wanted to play and i was
like ah yeah i'll be pretty keen but i
can't really can't make any trainings
because i'm working at blenheim it's oh
that's so good just show up on saturdays
and play so
i just did that for pretty much half the
season in 2020 after the cove right
that's crazy yeah so here you are you've
gone through the ranks you've played for
tasman you've been training with the
blues and then you just
you just pretty much you say you've had
enough and go back to building so when
you've done that did you feel like you
were always going to go back to rugby or
you're not sure did you feel like you
maybe had enough of it uh i still wasn't
sure i just wanted to get my building
apprenticeship done so i had the
qualification
and so if i ever wanted to travel and go
build or play rugby that was sort of it
yeah so i didn't want to be stuck
after rugby yeah that sort of stuff
and then i just sort of wanted like the
enjoyment factor of beckon yeah back
into it that's why i had a couple bees
games with my mates and that was real
fun i enjoyed that a lot
and then i was i won a challenge so then
i think
you were playing and i said oh i'll just
ask him for a few games and then yeah
got a few games and that was pretty fun
we actually made the semi
that yeah that was all good but then
lost you killed it but i was actually i
started get real skinny yeah because i
just wasn't doing any physical like gym
work or anything so that yeah i was
playing i looked like a rat
i got back down to probably like 75 74
kilos i probably lost like 10 kilos sure
yeah
i started i started getting a bit
because i probably wasn't eating the
best when i was up blues i got a little
bit tubby yeah i got to like 85 yeah it
wasn't like there's a lot of sort of
muscle but sort of getting like a belly
[ __ ] and then i just lost all my weight
i don't know how i'm probably just
working wasn't eating stuff or when i
wasn't going to the gym yeah and then
started start of this year i started
going back to the gym out with walker
just use it for free because i said it
was sweet air so went out there just go
in the mornings sure the other boys were
there in the morning so i just left
weights and then ended up getting my
weight back up so that was all good i
got it back up to like
84. um
so that was a good oh sweet
bloody good pre-season though yeah
brendan's a good coach you sort of run
us around a bit it was pretty good i
love that and then
yeah pre-season was mean we had a good
double trip luca organized that
that was pretty hectic
it was probably just
three solid days of drinking
yeah
oh go on there's some stories there i
can see you hold it back no we um
my mate vito picked me picked me up from
my house we go to the
hooyah club room it's about seven
o'clock in the morning i'm like
so i've got friday off work so i was
like yeah that's all right so i grabbed
a few
a few beds outside i was like right and
then just start cracking into it like
seven o'clock
and then
probably by the time we got the nest in
a few deep and then we're just on the
boat
just drinking up and we stopped at okiwi
bay for a fish
and by the time we get to devil probably
a few deep and then
the rest of the day was just blur for me
to be honest i just went that quick
we probably did more piss drinking than
fishing
to be honest
and so that was pretty fun and then yeah
i probably i probably cocked it at about
10 11 yeah
yeah and then back into it in the
morning
that was probably the
best present pre-season thing i've ever
been on shout out
one thing you one thing you spoke about
before about
your brother and sort of the pressure
that him being successful sort of put on
you do you did you feel like that was
external or did you feel like that was
internal just putting it on yourself or
did you get lots of comments from people
always comparing you because i mean i'm
in a i was obviously in a similar boat
with my brother as well uh probably a
bit of both to be honest yeah i'd get
the old oh
oh you're going to be in the marco
certain all that sort of yeah
you'll be playing super rugby soon yeah
and i was like ah
i was like sweet things like
i was like
i don't really want to hear that yeah
yeah don't want to be rude or anything
yeah and then
yeah so i got that quite a bit and like
oh sometimes you get oh you're just
there because your brother's in there
stuff like that yeah i was uh
sort of just brushing it by and then
yeah probably start again bit to me
mentally yeah
and then yeah probably mentally more
yeah i think that's probably why i
stopped enjoying it no
maybe i'm only playing just because i
have to yeah sort of thing
so that's why i just
give it a break and then
refresh myself and just get away from
the rugby rugby side of things and then
just
get into
some hobbies like playing golf started
playing golf
and just started hanging out with my
mates back home just
enjoying life again all that sort of
stuff true so what was it mental health
like up in auckland you know when you
were hiding away in the room did you
feel like it was
anything more than just wanting to be
by yourself
yeah probably got a little bit depressed
up there probably homesick more than
anything yeah i think a little bit of
depression
that probably kicked in
just because i
was just by myself the whole time yeah
oh just thought i had to be there just
because and i was like oh
then i got a bit homesick because i had
didn't have a car or anything yeah
couldn't just do several things like go
to the grocery store yeah
like auckland's a nice place like
because i'm into my fishing and stuff
and if i had my ute up there or had my
time over again
i would have tried to get a car and i
don't know go to the beach or something
do some fishing we'll go up to northland
and try
do some fishing off the rocks or just
ask for the boys
and like go diving and stuff like that
yeah so you're going to drive up to
moana this year yeah i'm taking my eu
it's going to be a big drive supposed to
be taking jim up there oh yeah i don't
think he can drive manually so i'll be
stuck the whole way
so i'll be taking all my i'm going to
take all my dye stuff yeah that sort of
stuff
and try to get in the water oh that's
good that's good that you've learned
something from that experience
just probably having hobbies yeah i
didn't really have a hobby back then
yeah i'll just
code and playstation yeah pretty much
code and playstation that was probably
what i was into but now i actually get
out a bit and play a bit of golf and
enjoy my fishing getting outdoors and
just finished my dive ticket i haven't
actually been diving after that though
yeah probably need to get up get my gear
my dive gear mum's been on to me about
it for ages
i've just
been in but they only had exhales so
then i haven't been
do you think new zealand rugby need to
do anything about your sort of situation
there because i know you're not the only
one who's been into a team environment
and had
a pretty average setup i remember mike
coleman on his one he was sleeping on
the couch at a friend's house training
with the hurricane so maybe not the only
one who's been given a pretty average
setup um
yeah probably just the injury
replacement players
like they probably get treated a little
bit different right when i was up there
they
had that passing of um mikey t yeah they
that just happened it was a jury
replacement part i didn't know anything
about it or anything
i don't know if what the cause before
that before but
yeah like just that way sort of injury
replacement players might get treated a
little bit yeah i guess like you just
get thrown in there and you're like oh
you don't know what's happening next
it's sort of a week by week thing yeah
but
i probably could have reached out but
didn't really know how to talk to anyone
back then yeah and that sort of stuff
but yeah but i reckon they could
probably get onto it a bit more maybe i
don't know
just check in every month before the
injury replacement players and just have
like a meeting with just the injury
replacement players yeah just checking
on them and stuff like that that's crazy
did you know mikey was struggling no i
said completely out of the blue that was
completely out of blood i didn't know
that yeah that's because i sort of got
up there after it yeah and i didn't i'd
never really i'd never met him or
anything yeah i just heard about it when
i got up there
so sad hey so sad to hear those sort of
stories
um
so we've sort of spoken about how you've
got back to tasman you obviously carved
up the club season this year probably
the form club player in their nelson
comp you found your love for the game
again so have you found it being back in
the tesla marco jersey yeah it's bloody
fun i enjoyed this season a lot it's
probably been funnest yet i'd say yeah
coming from the club season like i'll
just play with no worries and yeah just
enjoying it and like just seeing
when you're enjoying it you just just go
with the flow pretty much so you just
see what's funny and you just play it
it's been real eye opener um coming back
into the setup like a professional
environment semi-professional
and just learning all the stuff again
like
you come from club and you're like oh
yeah i think you think you know heaps of
stuff and then you come back into there
like [ __ ]
you've got a long way to go get all that
tiny detail maybe micro details yeah
it's the micro detail sort of stuff you
gotta look in like yeah and he's real
good at it
he's bloody good just like on the scrub
moves and what he's looking for and all
that sort of stuff yeah just the little
things in it
so that's probably a big learner for me
probably getting better at like
reviewing and previewing games yeah
way better than i was when i first came
in
i probably would would have barely done
any i'll just play
yeah it was
probably but now actually look at a few
other things yeah and look at what i've
done wrong and like
because the drones up there it doesn't
miss anything
catches everyone catches everyone out
yeah those little things so they keep
you honest yeah and the boys keep you
honest at training so it's good i enjoy
it i'm not one of those guys that gets
salty at someone who gives me a spark up
yeah i'll take it on the chin and i
don't know if you're used to them from
david he used to be the ultimate yeah
he'll tell you when you're [ __ ]
speaking of sprays obviously we have
some pretty intense trainings gst
training is always pretty intense you
got any um good stories from your times
and those
um
probably a couple times i just missed a
few of the queues like the pictures you
know we're getting the huddles and
anxious going going at me
and then i'm like [ __ ]
it's got to be on here
but i i enjoy that sort of stuff it like
keeps me honest yeah i know yeah
it's a bloody work on yeah and
i enjoy that so that's good keep it up
nick vancouver was not shy of a spray is
it [ __ ] no loves it but it's good for
you
make you a better rugby player yeah all
right
probably on
i think it was the auckland game got
pretty intense after the first block
because
boys were sort of running for a little
bit and then
they just huddled up onto the second
brighter lightning stuff this we're just
going to chop some people then we start
getting in their faces and they started
getting a bit flustered and it was quite
good actually then
started turning into tackle yeah then
yeah
always does ah yeah
i kind of like it when it turned the
table mate you're a chop tackle was it
anyway mate so what what's your plans
going forward like you've got moana
coming up which is an exciting thing and
then is it with tasman next year uh now
i've got no provincial contract for next
year or anything so
i used to just see how the moana thing
goes and yeah keep in touch with my
agent and see what's around me i'd love
to stay in tasman because it's home yeah
i really enjoy the place but if there
was an opportunity to go play 10
somewhere else i'd probably take it to
be honest yeah
just just because i want a bit more
experience and like having to run my own
team stuff like that yeah i'd love to
stay in tasman probably no no the
problems i'd rather be it might they
need to get on to asap for the sounds of
things
let's do something i'm still sticking
around here i love this place i love it
and i know there's whispers about you
playing for tonga early in the year
against all blacks so what what happened
there
um
i sort of
i didn't have really anything set in
stone with tasman right i was still like
on the fringe of it yeah not not really
on like a week by week training contract
or nothing so
i didn't really want to go and leave and
then come back to nothing sort of thing
and
thought i'd just stick around here
do all the pre-season games with tasman
and then just see what i got and
see what my performances put out there
yeah
the gamble paid off and then got
just got us i got a six week just weekly
training contract and then
because i must muster the tank right in
the canterbury and 20s game and then
got there and then yeah so
but then they were playing they sort of
and they wanted me to come on the end of
year tour
and then i was started arming and airing
because tasman season was still going
and
just with the covered stuff i wasn't
sure about like the spots yeah my cues
and
didn't want to really get stuck over
there all that sort of stuff i didn't
really want to take the risk but
yeah that
could still be an option for next year
now that with moana so yeah
i think they've got another world cup
qualifier game because that's still not
qualified for the world cup yet
but yeah so
i'll be i'm open to
to go in there all right there would be
cool be good just to
get there and learn a bit of my dad's
dad's side of heritage yeah i'd probably
have to learn to speak tongan first
i'm a plastic
what do you think about the rule of um
letting
x all blacks or other nations be able to
play for tier two nations like tonga
yeah i reckon should be 100 yeah it
should be should just be if you got two
passports yeah too possible she should
just be allowed to go i mean you can't
just keep chopping and changing yeah i
guess you gotta sort of stick but like
if you've only played like a handful of
tests and
you're gone overseas or whatnot i don't
think you should really
have a stand down like
you're overseas you're not playing in
new zealand because you have to be
playing in new zealand to make the all
blacks firstly anyway so you're sort of
stuck
if you go overseas and you play for the
all blacks like well now i've got to
wait a stand down period
i reckon they should just let them play
and then probably give the nations like
tonga samoa
even fiji like a bit more shot like they
do in league mate 100 percent the team
would be strong as teams would have like
pear towers and future paying for them
it would definitely um
lift the level of those pacific island
sides yeah like you see in the league
tonga be in australia yeah
that's just
through the roof there yeah it'd be real
good for just the pacific island nations
and you've you've already spoken about
your building so your life after rugby
sorted it's obviously a common question
for a lot of guys
um who are playing footy what they're
gonna do afterwards but it must be
pretty cool um to know what you're gonna
do after footy and have that all sorted
already yeah it's good now i've got no
worries like yeah don't have i don't
have two things on my mind i can just
focus on one thing so that's sort of
reasoning behind finishing it all if i
get injured or create any injury or
anything touch what i don't yeah
i can just go back do building qualified
so it's always going to be there they
need builders
and all that sort of stuff so it's
sorted out yeah sorted yeah hopefully my
mates finish his apprenticeship when he
starts the business
[Laughter]
no pressure anyway mate as always we've
gone to instagram for some questions and
all your macra have come up pretty heavy
with a lot of questions in this one so
um first question how important was
finishing your building apprenticeship
yeah pretty important a lot
if you can do it while you're balancing
rugby that's even better it's just it's
just harder if you make it like
professional environments because you
sort of have to put it all on hold yeah
but
pretty good i'd say if you're not good
at school or you're just not passionate
about school and like you're not really
into sports and get into building quick
and you can do it real fast earn some
good money yeah right if you're like a
16 17 year old and you're
sort of not really like into school yeah
and not just just there because you have
to be there yeah you can sort of
get out there and go get a labouring job
or something you pick up heaps of stuff
and then
what by the time you're 1920 if you're
qualified you're getting all good money
so probably pretty important for when i
finish rugby great advice for young kids
who are struggling and no good at footy
yep
okay next question ask him about the pub
crawl and blenheim in the after party
this one must be good yeah um
me and grooby
scrubies and a lot of these stories went
over to blenheim about
about 10 in the morning
thought i had a big one on friday
so we woke up but that's he stopped the
bk because his pup call had been
organized for about four months yeah so
i've got a bit of go over and then got
over to blenheim at about 12 we all
brought bikes on the dump so it was just
like a puppy around them when all the
pubs around blenheim did all that
and then after that there was a little
party on and then check the chick that
was hosting the party had boxing gloves
there
and then um all the boys decided to be
heroes and put on the boxing gloves and
think that
funny mike tyson
and then we all started boxing each
other and then there's a couple goodies
in there
shout out to boise he pretty much got
knocked out
and
yeah i was up against my mate
he's just done a dirty act i've turned
my back
and he's tried cheap shot me
and then we then we started all right
we'll go again and then we both we both
hooked each other at the same time and
pretty much gave yourself freaking blood
mouth
we called it quits
then went back inside and started
drinking
i couldn't even i just lost track of
time because my phone died yeah and then
i know i must have got that drunk
i pissed in a wardrobe
[Music]
and then um without knowing consciously
knowing all yeah
no
i like was there but i wasn't there so i
was like what are you doing and i said
oh
that was probably not a good one
and then
i ended up getting put into bed with one
of the other mates yeah and then i'm
just woken up at a random hour
and then i'm like oh where's everyone
going it's the party finished and
everyone's about to go to bed
[ __ ]
so i've probably missed like four hours
of the party and i've woken up when
everyone's gone
you've done some stupid [ __ ]
but you're always asleep
oh and that one sort of goes on to this
one this one came from your good mate
grooby ask him about pissing the bed
twice in one night
you sound like a serial pisser
no i'm not
i've only done it
that was the only time i've done it
that was the one and only time i've done
it it was after lockdown yeah and um one
of my mates said
it wasn't a big party it was a little
party
and then went over there
i had a few boxes what were you drinking
those smooth off vodkas oh yeah those
guana ones like seven percenters
um we ended up just having too much to
drink
and probably there to start about three
and then i was feeling fine i was all
good i was
sitting on the couch next to my mate
i was taking videos of my other mate
because he was smashed and yeah all of a
sudden i just blacked out
and groovy groovy's carrying me to the
room and my mother made like arms leg
i'm just dead weight and then
grubby thought i was hot yeah just
because i was like trying to pull my
clothes off oh he's hot he's hot so he
takes off my clothes
he's like trying to take off my pants
and i pull my pants now i'm pissed in my
mate's room
just on the floor
and then i've woken up at like 7 30 in
the morning
i don't have my jockeys on i've got my
mate's duckies on it's like the spear
room
and i've i've pissed my pants and
took my two other mates and next to me
and like i'll just press the bed while
they're in there
yeah a little bit that was after
lockdown i've been a long time away from
the lads
that was when i wasn't playing rugby
i was just enjoying myself yeah mate
were you what pissing the bear loving
life it's good stuff okay
next one favorite player to play with
well if i played with my brother once so
he'd be up there i want to get get a few
more games with him yeah hopefully
they did eventually
love playing with leicester yeah he's a
beast yeah i also love watching jim play
mm-hmm that means she's got no fear you
just run straight at anyone yeah um
hunty's good to play off yeah yeah i've
only pretty much played with the tassie
boys
he's just named the teddy backline love
it pretty much
what a sight
here's here's a good one um ask him
about the time he went fishing and
forgot to put the bungs in the boat
yeah that was funny um my granny's got
this little fiberglass boat yeah and um
i just used to take it out just for a
bit of fun
with my mates and i was with my
teammates and then
you know i told kai terry
and i reversed
dropped them in the water and i was
driving up the boat ramp and i was like
oh [ __ ] hang on i didn't put the bungs
in i put my head out the window and i
was like
you boys put the bungs in and then
my mate's in there
and um on the ground holding the head on
his finger in it there's water going in
the hole
sweet hop reverse back in and
and um pick it up and put it back on the
trail and all this water just come right
out of the house there's someone just
sitting there like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then yeah so don't assume your mates
have put the bungs in just do it
yourself oh another good lesson you're
full of it
okay two more questions any advice for a
skinny rugby player
some inspiration
from one of the skinny guys um
no you don't i guess you don't it's not
all about the size yeah i'm not the
fastest either it's just about how you
think about approaching the game and
just
having a better ticker i guess right
yeah you're not going to be able to get
dominant tackles on the biggest players
but you can still just take their legs
out and they're not going to run yeah so
i'll just say just have a bit of ticker
and no fear probably
as [ __ ] as um shayna would say ciao yeah
just get stuck in can you coach that you
reckon or dude i think you need to have
a bit of that
i've probably started at a young age
right around quite a bit when you're
young you've got an older brother that
you just play rugby with the whole time
i guess you're just built into it you
know you could
you could coach it but
just depends how you want to approach
like
the contact situation mindset yeah it's
pretty much mindset like i don't really
care i'll just go on with reckless
abandonment yeah like that yeah
that rucksa this needs a big gun all
right i'll just throw my whole way into
it if i don't clean them out you've
tried everything yeah i've done
everything yeah mate love that okay last
one best piece of advice you have to
share
i don't know i guess
if you're struggling with like your
mental health like
just speak up i guess that's probably
what i'd learned yeah i went to a few
counseling sessions yeah the lady said
oh just normal like a normal teenager
just yeah
but you know
if it can creep in so like you don't
have to be ashamed like
i'm not ashamed
i don't really talk about it because
like it's been there done that yeah
someone asked me i'll just tell them but
yeah
i guess i'm just speaking up right yeah
now these days all that sort of stuff
like
if yeah i just
i don't know because you might you might
seem happy on the outside but
on the inside no no so
probably just speaking up if you're if
you're a young man i mean 100 percent we
need a change today because obviously
it's still it is the number one killer
for new zealand males and that under 25
or whatever age it was
and you're right like some guys are just
so ashamed to be able to talk about that
but what was it like going to the
counselling and like what was what was
your experience like it was all good i
went for just a month like four sessions
yeah
they just they just sort of started like
your upbringing and all that sort of
stuff and like
pretty much like yeah it's like your
upbringing and how you've been like what
if you've had any troubles of like
traumas and stuff like that yeah so i
was pretty normal and i guess it was
probably just
putting too much pressure on myself like
all that sort of stuff
that's probably what it eventuated too
like
all the pressure and then
probably
you're just losing fun of fun and stuff
yeah and just probably just trying to
find hobbies just to keep yeah away from
rugby yeah that was probably my main one
but yeah was it hard to build up the
carriage to go to it or did you always
feel like it was never an issue i know a
lot of guys feel like it's a big issue
to go
to see someone like that but what was it
like for you
yeah i was little i sort of kept it in
the dark for a bit and retelling anyone
like my close mates you talk to them
they're all they'll fight about it
though
something's actually wrong yeah yeah and
then
talk to them but i sort of it was sort
of set up like with like nz like tasman
yeah so yeah
but yeah but i sort of just talked to my
good mate about it and he said oh
no that's all good as long as you're
you're happy yeah stuff like that i
think that's really important though
because i don't even think something has
to be wrong necessarily for guys to
be comfortable to go and speak to
someone like that who might just help
them or might think make them think
about something a little bit differently
so i guess probably nowadays like people
think oh
they just don't want to be ashamed to
talk to another guy about it yeah
nothing shameful about it right yeah
that's what it is it's part of life now
like you might talk to someone and he
might be feeling the same thing as you
said
i'm on the same page yeah yeah
well when you're vulnerable you open up
that vulnerable space and then people
become vulnerable with you so
mate and when big superstars like
yourself come on here and speak about
that and being vulnerable yourself is
only going to do massive things for
um other young kiwis out there listening
to this podcast hopefully so mate really
appreciate you coming on the podcast um
like i said at the start mate you're one
of the most underrated players in the
country really looking forward to seeing
you play not only the rest of the season
with tasman but
um when you get your crack with moana
pacifica and
potentially tonga down the road so mate
really looking forward to following your
journey and
mate you're an absolute lad cheers mate
thanks for having me jimmy martin
pleasure right you're a legend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you